el año nuevo trajo un hito para la
medicina doctores estadounidenses de la
universidad de maryland realizaron un
procedimiento nada convencional
trasplantaron el corazón de un cerdo
genéticamente modificado hacia un humano
nos alegramos bastante de que al
separarnos de la máquina cardiopulmonar
el corazón del animal funcionará con la
normalidad que se esperaba y esto varios
no amigos we care expect el paciente
tenía una enfermedad terminal y el
transplante era su única opción ya que
varios hospitales cerraron la
posibilidad de un tratamiento
convencional pero esta histórica cirugía
abre infinitas posibilidades según
expertos tenemos pacientes que están
muriendo en lista de trasplante y
teniendo esta posibilidad de modificar
los genes para que se impida el rechazo
para que impida que el propio organismo
rechace estos corazones de otras
especies como en este caso un cerdo
puede ayudarnos a tener una
disponibilidad mayor de estos corazones
para poder colocar en seres humanos y
salvarles la vida pero no solamente
corazón páncreas riñones y otros órganos
por otras enfermedades que también
afectan a los seres humanos los
cirujanos a cargo del trasplante
advirtieron que el reto ahora es
monitorear cómo reacciona el sistema
inmune del paciente a este nuevo órgano
hemos hecho esto en humanos y me gusta
pensar que nosotros le dimos una mejor
opción en lo que hubiera sido continuar
su terapia haber opción
pero si es un día una semana un mes o un
año no lo sé the week manager pero no la
lista de espera de órganos es demasiado
larga en eeuu 110.000 personas esperan
un trasplante y se calcula que al año
unas seis mil mueren antes de recibirlo